so you're mckenzie in the early 2000s
you're a ruthless consulting firm who
puts sales and capital above all else
and you've just found the perfect client
purdue pharma
produce sells one of the world's most
addictive and profitable products opioid
drugs like oxycontin imagine getting to
sell basically the equivalent of heroin
legally that is the business purdue was
in and mackenzie had just been hired to
boost their sales it was a match made in
heaven both you and purdue will do
anything to make an extra buck so you
set out on a disinformation and sales
campaign unlike any other
you sell people drugs you know will kill
them eventually mckenzie advised purdue
how to avoid fda and pharmacy
restrictions because mackenzie knew
that people were overdosing and dying
and getting sick from oxycontin you sell
them so well that over the next two
decades hundreds of thousands of people
die from opioid overdoses and because of
that produce sales go up and you get
your consulting fees
your client sells drugs and profits off
of people getting addicted to them just
like a drug dealer except drug dealers
go to prison but because you're a
well-connected corporation you just need
to issue an apology and get away with
just a 600 million dollar fine when you
make over 10 billion dollars a year
a national health crisis billions in
taxpayer dollars to set up rehabs the
alleged indirect killing of thousands of
people and the worst you get is a
glorified place don't do this again
this is mckenzie the most evil
consulting firm in the world and this is
how they pull it off
[Music]
mckinsey was founded in 1926 by a
university of chicago professor named
james o mckenzie today is the oldest of
the big three consulting firms a
management consultancy like mckinsey is
filled with business and economic grads
from ivy league schools like harvard and
yale and they're hired to give advice to
big businesses on how to improve their
performance and efficiency they go into
big businesses and governments to find
them ways to make more money save more
money and streamline their organization
this could mean rearranging the way a
business is organized creating new
strategies to become more profitable or
just helping the leaders of a business
or country run a tighter ship if that
sounds boring you are right but think
about it they're getting paid huge
dollars by the biggest companies in the
world to give advice they don't have to
manufacture anything and that's why they
make over 10 billion dollars a year
mackenzie is one of the best in the
business but they're also ruthlessly
committed to profitability which is
always good for the businesses they're
consulting for but it's not always great
for the customers or the general public
and mckinsey has had his fair share of
scandals
enron the infamous bankruptcy that took
74 billion dollars of shareholder money
with it was created by an ex-mackenzie
employee jeff skilling mackenzie earned
millions from enron for promoting his
business model and offering consulting
services for over 20 enron projects
mackenzie also advised president trump's
team on anti-immigrant and migrant
detention policies they suggested
cutting spending on medical supplies and
migrant detention centers restricting
the caloric intake of detained migrants
and streamlining the deportation process
and that's not all remember the 2008
financial crisis yeah well mckenzie was
involved in that too mackenzie's 10-year
ceo rajat gupta was convicted of insider
trading from it and even after all these
scandals mackenzie still advises some of
the biggest companies and governments in
the world their clients include best buy
the us department of energy the
department of defense and even the u.s
postal service
even though they've been involved in
some seriously questionable schemes
their methods obviously work and they've
stayed in business today they have over
130 offices all over the world and serve
80 of the fortune 100 companies if there
is a true puppet master behind all these
giant corporations it is mackenzie and
after nearly 80 years in business you
were stronger than ever so when the
chance came for you to team up with a
pharmaceutical company that shared your
hunger for profits and sales
well it was time to go all out
if you want to make a lot of money in
business one important aspect you might
overlook is your health after all health
is wealth it doesn't matter how much
money you have if your health isn't
there and you can't make as good of
business decisions when you're unhealthy
either that is where nume comes in nume
is a digital health platform that uses a
combination of science and support to
help people form healthier habits
because healthier habits are a lot more
effortless to follow once you have the
tools to learn them and noom doesn't
tell you how to live your life instead
noon creates a personalized plan that
teaches you how to meet your health
goals without depraving yourself here's
how it works first you tell nume about
your gender age eating habits and how
much activity you do daily then based on
your responses noon creates a
personalized plan to fit your lifestyle
and a timeline for reaching your health
goals from there you're ready to start
developing healthier behaviors at home
neum uses real psychology and therapy
techniques that lead to long lasting
changes in your habits
part of the reason why nume is so
effective is that their plans focus on
educating numerous instead of
restricting them one feature that's
really helpful in this learning process
is the daily new lessons on top of the
lessons noom has a food and exercise
tracker so you can stay organized and
know precisely how many calories you're
munching on every day and nume also
comes with an awesome support system
you're paired with a gold specialist
training psychology fitness and
nutrition who acts as your one-on-one
coach you can message your goal
specialist about anything related to
your health journey like when you're
having trouble sticking to your workout
schedule or you need advice about making
meals with leafy greens that actually
taste good if you've been frustrated
with how to take control of your health
start by creating a fast simple and free
nume evaluation that will help you
create your own custom health plan by
going to noom.com jake tran with the
link below that's noon.com jaytram with
the link below thanks to noon for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
less than one percent of people get
addicted to oxycontin
that's not possible
but it is
[Music]
companies like facebook instagram have
to put in a lot of work to build an
addictive product but what if you could
shortcut all that nonsense by just
selling a thing that will always be
extremely addictive at a molecular level
well that's what purdue pharma came
across in the 90s oxycontin oxycontin is
a doctor prescribed painkiller that was
originally made to help cancer patients
deal with pain it belongs to the same
class of drugs like heroin and fentanyl
called opioids think of this business
kind of like big tobacco on steroids for
years purdue pharma made millions from
selling the drug and telling doctors
there was no way it was addictive so
doctors were prescribed for everything
from tooth aches to sprained ankles yes
an addictive painkiller made as a last
resort for cancer patients was being
used for toothaches but then in the
early 2000s they ran into a problem
people were starting to realize
oxycontin wasn't as great as purdue
advertised
suddenly sales nose dived doctors
stopped prescribing it so liberally and
everyone got a lot more careful with the
medication they were taking
something had to be done purdue farmer
was sitting on a multi-billion dollar
product they couldn't sell because
people thought it was addictive
they needed help and that's when purdue
farmer called mckenzie and asked how do
we keep drugging america not sure if
that's how the call actually went and
you mckenzie couldn't wait to take over
the operation in 2004 mackenzie was
brought on board as the management
consultant and the race to turbo charged
profits began
[Music]
of all doctors in the country will be
sent pseudo-addiction pamphlets give one
to any doctor if their patients show
signs of addiction sorry
pseudo addiction your first order of
business was to find ways to boost
produce oxycontin sales to do that you
would allegedly have to do exactly what
big tobacco did convince people that all
the news about opioids being addictive
and bad for america was really just
speculation it wasn't the opioids fought
people got addicted they were just using
it wrong so you went on a full-blown
alleged disinformation campaign purdue
reps would tell doctors oxycontin was
way less addictive than other opioids
they would encourage them to prescribe
higher doses of oxy to their patients
and even after purdue was found guilty
of lying to doctors about the risk of
the drug they just kept selling and
allegedly mckenzie was at the heart of
all these tactics
mckenzie consultants actually rode along
with went with purdue sales reps to
doctors offices here in massachusetts to
critique them on how effective they were
at selling oxycontin with sales back on
the rise you had another problem to deal
with the fda mackenzie was already
advising the fda on drug regulation
policies while you also conveniently
forgot to tell them you were consulting
for purdue while at the same time
mckenzie went to opioid manufacturers
and suggested you could help them avoid
quote strict treatment from the fda
and it worked with fewer restrictions
and doctors being told oxy was the best
opioid out there drug money went on the
rise and so did the addiction rates
[Music]
opioid sales were rising faster than
ever which meant you and perdue had a
new problem people dying people would
get addicted to opioids like oxycontin
accidentally take too much of it to get
high and then overdose you knew the
opioids produced sold were dangerous but
who cares you and perdue were swimming
in drug money and you weren't gonna let
a few people dying stop you again
allegedly so you got a brilliant idea
you needed pharmacies to keep selling
oxy but they probably wouldn't want to
if the overdoses affected their business
so what if purdue offered pharmacies a
rebate for every person that died or
became addicted to oxycontin pharmacies
would have no reason not to work with
purdue anymore think about it if purdue
paid let's say fourteen thousand eight
hundred ten dollars per event an event
being a person getting addicted or dying
and let's say 2 484 customers at a cvs
pharmacy chain overdose or became
addicted perdue would only have to pay
cbs 36.8 million dollars for the trouble
a pretty good deal and just simple math
and this is a real presentation mckinsey
made by the way at the same time you
were pushing opioid sales higher you
even had the audacity to post articles
with titles like why we need bolder
action to combat the opioid epidemic but
then perdue got exposed and things
turned ugly
[Music]
around 2018 purdue was already under
investigation and mckenzie's top
executives started realizing the amount
of trouble they could be in if their
work to push opioid sales were uncovered
it was only a matter of time before
investigators got to you so the only
logical choice was to destroy evidence
according to one mackenzie executive
they were deleting all of their quote
documents and emails anything that could
get you in trouble for your methods but
clicking delete on a multi-million
dollar deal where hundreds of people
involved didn't really help much and
investigators eventually found all the
documents mackenzie was trying to hide
and the spotlight was on you
[Music]
as with every company that has ties to
us politicians the punishment for
mackenzie's involvement in produce
opioid free-for-all was pretty much a
slap on the wrist purdue farmer got
destroyed they were forced to shut down
and to pay billions of dollars to help
rehabilitate people but mackenzie you
got a tiny 600 million dollar fine and
basically a request to stay out of the
opioid industry forever considering you
make over 10 billion dollars in revenue
a year 600 million dollars is a setback
but it's definitely not a harsh
punishment only six percent of revenue
the closest thing to an apology anyone
could get out of mackenzie a three
paragraph blog post titled mackenzie's
statement on his past work with purdue
pharma about how you never expected this
will happen and in true business
consultant style you even found a way to
make your find and produce downfall a
little bit sweeter
[Music]
most of the money you and purdue made
will go to funny state-run addiction
treatment centers and rehabs which is
great for mckenzie because one of your
wholly owned hedge fund affiliates mio
partners has indirect stakes in not just
drug rehabs but the manufacturers of
medication used to treat overdoses you
profited from opioid addiction and now
you'll likely allegedly profit from
people getting rehabilitated from it too
mackenzie sent out a spokesman to call
this allegation false and absurd for
decades you have been playing the system
and you definitely aren't going to stop
now but if you thought that was the most
atrocious thing mckenzie advised on that
is not even close see mckenzie was
allegedly one of the main firms that
sold out america to china by telling us
companies just how much money they would
make if they ship their operations
across the world to china but you would
just have to subscribe for that future
video
[Music]
[Music]
you